[Musique]
sur le campus de l'université de tsukuba
une des dix meilleures au japon voici
les serres où le professeur hiroshi et
jura a fait naître des tomates d'un
nouveau genre
tout çà de là là ce sont des tomates à
haute quantité de gabat est ici ce sont
des tomates normal qu'on a utilisées
pour l'expérience
comme vous le voyez
l'apparence est la même
gaba un acide présente naturellement
dans le fruit aux effets bénéfiques sur
le sommeil et la tension artérielle
les chercheurs japonais ont eu recours à
l'édition du génome ils ont modifié le
matériel génétique d'une tomate sans
rien ajouter d'extérieur c'est la
différence avec les ogm en utilisant la
technique des ciseaux moléculaires les
japonais ont coupé un brin de l'adn dans
lequel ses racines tant recherché était
particulièrement présents puis ils sont
parvenus à le réinsérer ailleurs mais
dans la même tomates
cette modification du génome la rend
plus riches en acide gaba première
mondiale ses tomates sont vendus en
ligne depuis septembre 20 euros le kilo
deux fois le prix des tomates en grande
surface
on utilise une nouvelle technique et
parce qu'on vient de commencer on n'a
pas encore beaucoup de quantité c'est
pour ça que le prix est un peu élevé
au japon les légumes sont chers et le
prix de nos tomates est juste un peu
supérieur à celui des tomates normal
haut de gamme
depuis mai dernier une expérimentation à
grande échelle a vu le jour 4000
volontaires ont reçu gratuitement des
plants de tomates au génome édité à eux
de les cultiver dans son petit jardin
près de tokyo ni écho aux yamaha a déjà
récolté des milliers de ces fameuses
tomates
on a famille et mes amis disent que
c'est tomates sont bonnes et qu'il se
sente mieux au niveau de leur santé
quand ils en mangent donc effectivement
je pense que petit à petit ça va se
répandre au japon au quotidien la
retraitée consigne ses données de santé
près d'un japonais sur trois souffre
aujourd'hui de problèmes de tension
artérielle
la faute à une alimentation trop riche
en sel et je mets les tomates
ce midi elle déjeune avec sa soeur elle
aussi convaincre un repas où tous les
plats contiennent les fruits du potager
bon appétit
thomas parages et l euro le goût de la
tomate est vraiment affirmer son
l'acidité et le sucre et
la technique utilisée ici est différente
des autres produits ogm si on comprend
la nuance ce n'est pas inquiétant
conséquence le japon distingue
clairement les produits issus de
l'édition génomique des produits ogm et
n'oblige pas les fabricants a mentionné
le procédé sur les emballages de quoi
susciter la méfiance des associations de
consommateurs sur les stands de cette
foire agricole tout est local est issu
de cultures biologiques
mais bien sûr que c'est bon un marché où
on ne veut pas entendre parler de
tomates modifier
ce n'est pas parce que les politiciens
ou les chercheurs disent que c'est bon
qu'on doit avoir confiance
des gens disent que ces produits peuvent
provoquer de nouvelles allergies
idem même si on croit avoir tout compris
je ne pense pas que ce soit le cas
selon une étude récente menée auprès de
40 mille japonais près de la moitié
refuserait de consommer des produits
issus de l'édition génomique
avait produit qu'on n'a pas envie de
manger qui vont arriver au supermarché
pour des personnes comme moi qui font
des courses sans réfléchir ça me fait un
peu peur on ne connaît pas les risques
on ne sait pas quand ça va arriver sur
les marchés
combien de japonais ont déjà acheté ces
tomates du futur à l'université dessus
cuba le professeur résumera ne nous le
dira pas secrets d'affaires
mais pour la première fois ils ouvrent
les portes de leurs antichambre voici le
laboratoire dans lequel on apporte les
germes aux genôts méditer pour les faire
pousser vous pouvez entrer
dans ce laboratoire on travaille déjà
sur de nouveaux projets car l'édition
génomique permet de tout imaginer des
tomates plus résistantes à la chaleur ou
au gel plus ou moins acide sucré ou
enrichis en vitamines des modifications
qui pourraient apparaître naturellement
et ne devrait pas faire peur
le risque est le même qu'avec des
croisements normaux sur des tomates
normale en les mangeant est-ce qu'on a
des problèmes de santé c'est la même
question
comment pendant ses tomates seront
bientôt sur les étals des supermarchés
japonais avant peut-être de s'exporter
la commission européenne est en train
d'étudier leur possible
commercialisation
elles sont aujourd'hui interdites en
europe